in the next few videos we'll take a look  at the tokenizers  in natural language processing most of  the data that we handle  consists of raw text however machine  learning models cannot read or  understand text in its raw form  they can only work with numbers so the  tokenizer's objective will be to  translate the text  into numbers there are several possible  approaches to this conversion  and the objective is to find the most  meaningful representation  we'll take a look at three distinct  tokenization algorithms  we compare them one to one so we  recommend you take a look at the videos  in the following order first word based  followed by character-based and finally  sunboard-based